10 Superheroes You Didn’t Know were Stolen
When comic book writers create superheroes,
they can draw inspiration from all kinds of
sources.
They can be based on real people - perhaps
someone the writers know personally or a famous
person they admire - and they can be based
on other fictional characters, but sometimes
they are quite clearly blatant rip-offs of
other comic book characters.
Marvel and DC may be bitter rivals, but that
hasn't stopped them from taking inspiration
from each other on numerous occasions when
it comes to character creation - in some cases,
it's to the extent that you could even say
they stole from each other.
Whether it's a character's name, their appearance,
or their general concept or schtick, a number
of Marvel and DC characters were obviously
copied - and we're going to run through a
few of them now.
Here are ten superheroes you didn't know were
stolen.
Wolverine
In most of these cases, the stolen characters
are either nowhere near as popular as the
characters they were based on, or, at best,
they have merely equalled the popularity of
their templates.
However, in Wolverine's case, he has surpassed
the character he was based on by a large margin.
That character was Timber Wolf - a DC character
who first appeared in 1964, ten years before
Wolverine - and the similarities between the
pair are staggering.
For starters, they look almost identical,
but the fact that they were both experimented
on and both have similar powers confirms that
Wolverine was stolen by Marvel.
Both characters have superhuman reflexes,
enhanced senses, a regenerative healing factor,
claws and super strength, and both are prone
to violent outbursts.
Who knew the most famous X-Man was ripped-off
from DC?!
Hawkeye
Hawkeye is the first character on this list
to prove that character stealing is a two-way
thing between Marvel and DC.
Having first appeared in 1964, he arrived
a massive 23 years after Green Arrow and is
blatantly modelled on his DC counterpart.
They're both ordinary humans fighting alongside
gods and metahumans, they both lost their
parents at a young age, Green Arrow has a
close relationship with Black Canary and Hawkeye
is close to Black Widow and, of course, there's
the most obvious similarity in that they're
both incredibly skilled with a bow and arrow.
Cyborg
Cyborg AKA Victor Stone is a DC character
and a prominent member of the Justice League
and Teen Titans.
He first appeared in 1980 and was quite obviously
copied from a Marvel concept that first hit
comic books in 1974.
That Marvel concept is Deathlok - the name
of several characters who had died and been
reanimated using cybernetic technology, which
is exactly what happened with Stone.
Although the Deathlok title has been bestowed
on a number of characters, what they all have
in common with Stone is a constant struggle
to retain their humanity and a difficulty
in coming to terms with being part-machine.
Swamp Thing
DC's Swamp Thing is probably the most obvious
rip-off of a Marvel character - that character
being Man-Thing.
Their names are obviously similar, they look
the same as each other and their powers and
back-stories are almost identical.
It should come as no surprise, then, that
Swamp Thing's creator, Len Wein, was living
with Man-Thing's co-creator, Gerry Conway,
at the time of the latter's creation.
Man-Thing first appeared on panel in May of
1971 and then, two months later in July, Swamp
Thing emerged.
Wein had clearly and shamelessly stolen the
idea from his housemate.
Aquaman
When it comes to underwater superheroes, there's
nobody more well-known than DC's Aquaman.
Although he's often unfairly the butt of jokes,
he's also an undeniably iconic character and
a founding member of the Justice League of
America - but he was actually a stolen idea,
inspired by Marvel's Namor the Sub-Mariner.
The two character's personalities couldn't
be more different, but their origins are near-identical.
They're both Atlantean royalty and were both
born when sea-dwelling princesses liaised
with human men.
And with Namor first appearing in 1939 - a
full two years before Aquaman - it's obvious
that it was Marvel's idea being stolen.
Sentry
There are so many Superman analogue characters
in comic books that we could easily fill a
video with them, but one of the most blindingly
obvious examples is undoubtedly Marvel's Sentry.
The man known as Robert Reynolds does have
some powers that differentiate him from the
Man of Steel, but his powerset is more or
less the same as Superman's; he possesses
super-strength, super-speed, incredible durability
and flight.
But Superman came 62 years before Sentry,
way back in 1938, and when you also bear in
mind that the latter wears a tight-fitting
costume with a cape and has an "S" on his
chest, the fact that he was a stolen idea
becomes all the more blatant.
Rocket Red
While there's no concrete evidence to suggest
that the idea for Rocket Red was stolen from
Marvel by DC, the comparisons with a certain
well-known character are obvious.
Iron Man first appeared back in 1963 and Rocket
Red didn't surface for another 24 years, and
while Tony Stark is an American billionaire
and Dmitri Pushkin is a kind-hearted Russian
with a taste for American culture, the red-powered
armour worn by the latter was obviously copied
from that of Iron Man.
Then, when you consider the fact that Iron
Man is a member of the Avengers and Rocket
Red fought with DC's counterparts - the Justice
League - you can clearly see where the influence
for the character came from.
Power Princess
Power Princess - also known as Zarda - is
Marvel's belated answer to Wonder Woman, and
the idea for the character was clearly stolen
from DC's iconic Amazonian warrior (albeit
41 years after Wonder Woman first appeared
back in 1941).
Like Wonder Woman, Zarda was raised on an
isolated and hidden island called Utopia Isle
and is a Greek Goddess.
She also became the first emissary to Earth,
fought in World War II and became romantically
involved with the first guy she met outside
of her home island - just like her DC counterpart.
Not only that, but their powers and abilities
are strikingly similar, all of which is clear
evidence that Marvel liked what they saw with
Wonder Woman and stole
the idea.
Bumblebee
DC's Bumblebee is the alter-ego of the company's
first African American supheroine, Karen Beecher-Duncan.
Having first appeared as Beecher-Duncan in
1976 - and a year later in her super-powered
form - the character's concept is clearly
stolen from Marvel's Wasp, who predates her
by thirteen years.
Both characters are tiny in size but display
an increase in strength in that form - although
Wasp can regrow to normal size and Bumblebee
can't - and there are undoubtedly parallels
in their physical appearances and their more
intricate powers and abilities, such as the
powerful concussive blasts that each character
can expel.
Deadpool
After starring in a fantastic 2016 movie,
Deadpool is the man of the moment in the superhero
world - but Marvel's Merc with a Mouth was
actually quite clearly ripped-off from a DC
character.
Deathstroke AKA Slade Wilson first appeared
in 1980, while Deadpool - whose real name,
Wade Wilson, is very similar to his DC counterpart's
- didn't appear until eleven years later.
Both characters are morally ambiguous anti-heroes
and mercenaries, both gained their healing
abilities through experiments, they both have
severe disfigurements that prompt them to
wear extremely similar-looking costumes, and
both regularly use guns, explosives and bladed
weapons - although Deadpool is undoubtedly
a hell of a lot crazier than Deathstroke!
Thanks for watching our list of 10 superheroes
you didn't know were stolen.
Did any of these surprise you?
Did we leave any major examples out?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one!